so should james comey be proud of his
conduct joining us now with more on the
progress of the inspector general report
is Texas Congressman John Radcliffe and
former congressman and Fox News
contributor trey Gowdy gentlemen thank
you so much for joining I served with
both of you in the Congress a
congressman Ratcliffe you were a former
US Attorney trey Gowdy and I served with
you we both abandoned you and left you
there to your lonesome
there on the Judiciary Committee but my
understanding is that you've had a
discussion with the Inspector General
just a few days ago tell us what
happened and what transpired Jason tried
good to see both of you yeah I didn't
have the opportunity to meet with
Inspector General Horowitz last week we
talked about his report the timing of
his report not the content and he
related that his team's investigative
work is complete and they're now in the
process of drafting that report so I
would expect that it will be a draft of
that will be completed in short order I
will tell you though Jason I don't
expect that any of us are gonna see it
anytime real soon he did relate that as
much as 20% of his report is probably
going to include classified information
so that draft report will have to
undergo a classification review at the
FBI and at the Department of Justice so
while I'm you know hopeful that we might
see it before members of Congress recess
for the August recess I'm not too
certain about that this is always the
frustrating thing it's happened multiple
times where we had reports when I was
the chairman when trey Gowdy was the
chairman the Department of Justice would
review things for weeks on end if not
months but it is encouraging note of the
Inspector General is going to be right
there around the corner
congressman Gowdy I got to tell you you
have a very definitive James Comey who
thinks he did everything by the book and
that he did everything that he was
supposed to but you and congressman
Radcliffe are the two people that I know
of that have actually reviewed the FISA
unredacted the FISA reports is director
Comey right is this just all for nothing
because he did everything the way it was
supposed to JC I just want to make sure
that we have the the the the right James
Comey is that that Comey that road he
didn't leak in a
that he later leet is that the james
comey that said he didn't do weasel
things while he was memorializing what
he said was a private conversation is
that the same james comey that said the
FBI didn't give a hoot about politics
while two of his senior aides spent the
better part of a year discussing two
political candidates that they were
supposed to be investigating yeah I
think the same James Comey the one that
you just played it it's just the same
one yeah yeah it's the same one that
took advantage of the Trump
administration by sending FBI agents to
interview Michael Flynn while I let
Hillary Clinton have a small law firm
when she was interviewed I just want to
make sure it's the same James Comey I
don't know what Horowitz is gonna find I
have a lot of confidence enemies a
straight arrow he's just looking at the
FISA abuse United States Attorney John
Durham is looking to what happened and
the the late winter in spring of 2016 so
your viewers have to have kind of a line
of demarcation just remember Peter
struck if that name sounds familiar and
late July 2016 initiates a
counterintelligence investigation into
the Trump campaign that's July of 2016
Horowitz is looking at the FISA process
after that Durham is looking at the
origins of the Russia investigation
prior to that and I'm hopeful that those
two investigations together will shed a
lot of light so America can know what
happened and then move on because it's
been a really divisive two years no it
has in in congressman Radcliffe again
you've been a US Attorney i you and trey
gowdy have reviews the reviewed the FISA
reports it says verified at the top and
I guess maybe if they want to debate
what verified means but you've actually
looked at the unredacted reports Comey
says he did everything right you too
have looked at and said it's not wrong
but that it was potentially done poorly
and wrong and and deceptively and maybe
exculpatory information was left out is
Horowitz going to be the definitive word
what is his role in this process I think
he's gonna be one of the more important
voices and a lot of folks are looking
forward to Bob Muller's testimony on
July 17th that's coming up but Bob
Mahler's going to talk about collusion
that didn't exist about obstruction that
the Attorney General found
didn't exist you can ask Bob Muller 10
times in 10 different languages and I
don't think there are gonna be any new
facts I don't think there gonna be any
new conclusions but Michael Horowitz and
his findings and John Durham and his
findings those are gonna be significant
those were late not to trump misconduct
but to potential Obama misconduct look
you know Jim Comey says they did
everything right even though as tre
pointed out you know you've got a the
lead investigator who promised to stop
Trump wanted to prevent him from
becoming president he had a deputy
director who lied under oath on multiple
occasions and was criminally referred
and as tre pointed out director Comey
himself leaked private conversations
with the president you know he has a
different parent Lee a different
definition of the word proud when he
says he's proud of all that work but
we'll find out Michael Horowitz I do
think his findings will be significant
Jason because it potent it presents a
real potential problem for the Democrats
right now we already know Bob Muller has
told us that a Democratic administration
started an investigation into conspiracy
with Russia that did not exist that's
bad enough
it'd be a whole lot worse if it turns
out that that same Democratic
administration continued that
investigation by breaking rules at the
FISA Court if that happens you can
pretty much put a pin in any impeachment
balloon because be hard for the
Democrats to say well we started an
investigation that we shouldn't have we
continued it by breaking the rules but
we want to impeach a president for
trying to obstruct that investigation
that never should have started so
congressman Gowdy let's go back to
director Muller who's coming to testify
you're no longer on the committee's that
would be questioning him what are the
Democrats up to why would they do this
and if you were the Rhian the Republican
side of the aisle what kind of questions
are you going to ask Muller well first
the easy part why are the Democrats
doing it because they're never held
accountable by the DC media I mean they
brought Michael Cohen and John Dean as
either fact with
or experts you would have been
excoriated as a chairman if you had
brought two witnesses like that but
they've got a safety net their net
they're never criticized you're calling
someone who doesn't want to come who's
not going to deviate from the four
corners of his report some of us didn't
even think his report should be made
public we sure as hell don't think you
ought to be testifying but they're going
to get a pass what should Republicans do
they should prepare you've got the best
lawyer in the house as your guest
tonight I'm not worried about Johnny
Ratcliffe he's fantastic but the other
members need to prepare and they need to
think in terms of tranches or buckets
what did Muller find
no criminal collusion what did he not
find an indictable obstruction of
justice offense what did he not bother
to look for Johnny just mentioned
collusion between the Trump campaign and
Russia we do know one campaign was
getting dirt from Russia did Muller
bother to find out whether or not the
Russian government was feeding that dirt
through Crist Christopher Steele to
fusion GPS did he even ask and the legal
issue that is really important and
Johnny just touched on it if you can
resist an unlawful arrest
can you really obstruct a none
predicated investigation which is why
it's important where Muller began and I
don't think he began by figuring out the
origins of the Russia probe as it
relates to Trump but we'll find out
prepare set low expectations is five
minutes it's impossible to unlock the
mysteries of the world in five minutes I
wish they weren't having the hearing I'm
really glad that we got a good lawyer
like Johnny Radcliffe there's on
judiciary know a lot of us wish you
could just pour all the questions into
that bucket but gentlemen it was a
pleasure and honor to serve with both of
you and I thank you for your service and
Congressman Radcliffe we wish you the
best in Godspeed in these upcoming
hearings again thank you gentlemen